- Yeah, well, equity is another,
it's a synonym for the
sort of the adverse
which is racism and
white supremacy.
I've been hearing, more of
my ears are more attuned
to Biden's endless repetition
of systemic racism.
And they're the same thing.
I mean equity is the
response to systemic racism.
Equity means quotas, it
means the destruction
of meritocratic standards.
It means you hire and
promote on the basis of race
not on the basis
of qualifications
and any institution
which does not show
a proportional number
of blacks or
Hispanics is thereby
by definition systemically
racist and engaged in bias.
(mellow music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
joining me today is a fellow
at the Manhattan Institute.
A contributing editor
at City Journal
and author of the
"Diversity Delusion".
Heather Mac Donald, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- It's great sort of
being with you Dave
as close as we can be.
- As close as we
can be at the moment
but that's a good place to start
because you are a
New York City girl
but you have fled
New York City to go
to California during a lockdown.
What's going on
over there, Heather?
- Who would believe it
but actually New York
is more insane at least
than Orange County.
I'm in Irvine and here
at least I can swim
which is very important
to my mental health,
my overall health.
New York City is in a
state of utter hysteria.
My pool makes it virtually
impossible to swim.
So here it feels a little saner
without restaurants in New
York, without the opera
there's really no
point in being there
and of course it is turning
into a situation
of maximal squalor,
crime, threat, people getting
assaulted on the streets.
So I don't know when I'm
gonna go back frankly.
I bought a one-way
ticket out here
and it's still waiting
for any reason to go back
and I don't see one.
- Yeah, well, there you go.
For the people
that would say who
in their right mind
would go to California
in the midst of all of this?
we found one person and
she's coming from New York.
So that kind of says it all.
Look, everything that
I've talked to you
about over the last
couple of years,
you've been on the
show a few times.
It seems that everything that
you've been writing about,
that you've been studying
all of these things,
they seem to all be kind of
coming to fruition right now.
So we're gonna try to hit
on a whole bunch of stuff
but I guess first since
you have fled New York
to come to Cali, are
you surprised in any way
that these big government
progressive lefty policies
are ruining these
cities and states?
- No, what I have
been surprised by
is how perfectly the response
to this pandemic
mirrors political
pre-existing categories.
It's very curious
that there is something truly
fundamental constitutional
in the way people view the world
that there should be
so clear a distinction
between red state
individuals who by and large
are locked down skeptics
and then in the blue states,
the willingness of vast
majority of the population
to put up with rules that
are utterly arbitrary.
I mean they're made
up out of whole cloth,
the distinctions about
when you can go out,
how many people you can have
at a table, it's ridiculous
and yet the passivity of
the population before this
is completely remarkable.
So it seems like
there is in fact,
something very profound in
the way people's psyches
are constructed with
regards to their attitudes
of either credulity
or skepticism
towards the assertion
of elite power.
And I am very grateful
today for giving me
the opportunity to
say, I told you Trump
because I've been
and you have too.
Those of us who have been
warning about the landslide
of poison that's been
coming out of the university
for decades and people kind
of turn their eyes away
and they say, oh, haha, it's
so funny these snowflakes,
it's not funny guys.
The whole safety is a
metric that is a feminist,
a feminine ideology
of victim hood
and the aversion to
risk an entrepreneurship
that we see in universities now
with this whole
wellness initiatives
and people leaving safe spaces
that is COVID writ large,
it's the safety as a
metric against the spirit
of entrepreneurship
and risk-taking.
- You're giving me so
much to work with there.
So as someone that loves numbers
because you're always diving
into the actual numbers
of what's going on
in our inner cities,
what's happening at the
places of go at this point,
quote, unquote higher
end et cetera, et cetera.
Was there any point when
the lockdown started roughly
a year ago at this point,
11 months ago at this point.
Was there any point
where you saw numbers
that made sense to do all of
the things that we've done?
So you know that first two
weeks I was on the show saying,
let's do the two week lockdown
because every expert said two
weeks to flatten the curve.
I said, I'm not
an expert in this
but I'm gonna bring on some
experts to talk about it.
But I was worried from beat one
about the never ending
extension of all of this.
Did you ever see numbers
that were like, oh, okay,
this is what we have
to do right now.
- Well, Dave, I don't wanna
like toot my own horn here
but I have to say I was
first out of the gate
among conservatives and
locked down skepticism
with a piece in the
new criterion that
was compared to what
and it was putting what were
then the numbers in context
of other types of deaths
that we put up with.
I mean 40,000
highway deaths a year
that we could eliminate entirely
by reducing highway speeds
to 20 miles an hour.
We don't because we
are willing to say
there will be 40,000 lives lost.
We value our efficiency
and our convenience more.
And I have to say the
distinction I drew earlier
between liberal and
conservative views
wasn't completely accurate
because I was roundly attacked
by many conservative writers
for being willing
to kill off grandma.
But no, we saw in March,
the Italian Health
Agency publish data
on the characteristics
of coronavirus desinence.
Nothing has changed
since March 2020,
average age 80, almost three
comorbidities being obesity,
diabetes, heart disease and
then others like cancer,
nothing has changed.
We knew almost from the
start that this was a disease
that targeted the very
elderly even Neil Ferguson,
the author of that
infamous study
that was predicting 20 million
dead in the United States.
If we did nothing, even he
admitted that two thirds
of the people who
would die in 2020
from coronavirus would have
died anyway from other causes.
Now is it happy that they die?
Of course not, but to be honest,
death is the inevitable banal
mediocre end of all life.
And when you get to
be a certain age,
the New York Times has
this modeling section
that they run periodically
called Those We've Lost.
And in the list
like a 101-year-old
that have four wars.
And he's supposed to
be a coronavirus victim
as if he's gonna live
for another 20 years
without coronavirus,
they do this regularly.
- Yeah.
- We had 100 years,
no, it was 101-year-old
maybe 100, last of
the Tuskegee airmen.
Again, he's gonna
die of pneumonia
and he's probably dying
with not from COVID
which is the other
big slight of hand
that our public health
experts use to try
and inflate the death numbers.
- Were shocked when you
got some of that pushback
from conservatives, I remember
there was a specific day,
very early on maybe around April
where Ben Shapiro was on my show
and he said, what we
all know to be true
which is that you're
gonna have to live
with some amount of risk
as you just said, in a
certain amount of people
we just accept, they die as
part of the circle of life.
You don't want it to happen,
you mitigate the risks but
this is what actuaries do.
But I saw a ton of
pushback from conservatives
and it was like, wait,
since when do
conservatives believe
in a perfectly safe system?
I agree, and again, so I have
to complicate my initial black
and white sort of
mannequin distinction.
It is absolutely the case
that a whole lot of
conservative intellectuals,
took the ridiculous
attitude that was expressed
by governor Andrew
Cuomo initially that
if we can save just one life,
there's no amount of lockdowns
which will not be worth it.
Well, that is absurd.
If that had been the attitude,
there would be no
United States today.
There would've been
nobody who took off
from Plymouth Rock because
the chance of survival
in the transatlantic voyage
back then was about one in six.
And so it should be the hallmark
of not just conservatives
but of human rational
human beings to realize
that you make trade-offs
and that you balance one sort
of risk against the other.
But yes, I was very surprised
that conservatives had adopted
the safetism ethic which is to
focus on one particular type
of risk to the exclusion of any
other type of consideration.
And again, it gets wearisome
because all of these arguments
have been out there.
The argument that I've
made and others have made,
you've made which is, what
about deaths from suicide,
from untreated
illnesses cause people
are too scared out of their
minds to go to a hospital?
What about the destruction
of children across the globe
from the poverty, from
the lack of education,
we are consigning them to
lives of stunted capacity.
All of those trade-offs
are not being made.
So it's sort of the
core of conservatives
which isn't to say that
there aren't a whole lot
that we're just as
spooked as the liberals
with their math wearing
their masks at 5:00 a.m.
in Central Park when
there's six people spread
over 800 acres.
- Yeah, so you're not
gonna put on a mask
for the rest of this interview?
- (laughs) I'm
gonna get my virtue
from other means like that.
- Fair enough, what do you think
if you had to grade
the professional
class at this point,
if you had to grade the experts
because I think actually
the next coming crisis
that we're gonna have,
now we just go from
crisis to crisis
or at least, two
crisis's to another two
or whatever it is, is that
I think that a huge amount
of our experts have completely
lost all credibility.
When you see videos of Fauci
saying masks don't do anything
then wear a mask, now
two masks, may be kind of
and then Biden another 100
days, federal-mask mandate,
why should the people
in Montana be living
under the same rules as someone
in metropolitan New York City.
Just sort of the elite class,
do you think that they've
sort of done irreparable
damage to themselves?
- No, I don't.
- Oh, interesting.
- Well from an objective
point of view, yes.
- Right
- But what one has learned
over this last two years or so
and we knew that beforehand
is how profoundly powerful
one's preexisting conceptions
are and worldview.
So I don't think Fauci
is at all discredited
in that very large
portion of the population
that views the New York
Times as gospel truth.
And you are an optimist and
you think that most people
are skeptical of the liberal
worldview and ideology.
I'm not so sure about that.
And right now certainly
the liberal elites
are in the seat of power.
And the vote for Biden
as far as I was concerned
was sadly a vote
for safety at some.
It was a vote for turning
America's back on its history
of entrepreneurship and
risk-taking and rationality
and a sane attitude
towards what life is about.
Trump got a lot of votes
but Biden got more.
And so I don't know.
I think that the whole world is,
as Andrew Sullivan said,
we're all on campus now.
And this ideology
is very powerful
and the more people who
graduate from college,
the harder it's gonna be
to turn things around.
- Yeah, and yet there
were plenty of people,
we've talked about it
before telling you and I,
I mean, I remember
when we did an event,
I think at Berkeley
together saying,
you guys are making this up.
This is, it'll just
stay on college campuses
and then what do
they always say?
Then they'll go out to the
real world while apparently
the real world didn't have
many safeties equipped.
- Well, the big lie on
college campuses for decades
has been that the characteristic
that defines America
above all else is racism.
And so you have this cultivation
of a victim mentality
where to be a female
on a college campus
is to be at risk of what's life
whereas in fact, there's
nothing more privileged
than being an American
female anywhere
but on a college campus,
are you kidding me?
I mean, the whole place
is run by females too,
it's utter destruction
or to be a under URM
as the jargon goes
and I heard today
that somehow acronyms
are now racist.
I didn't get the explanation
but I'm not surprised
because everything is racist,
- Everything is racist.
But to be a URM which is
Under-Represented Minority
is also to be at risk of what
not withstanding the fact
that every single college
with any kind of selectivity
ties itself into knots to admit
as many Blacks and Hispanics
as possible with test scores
that would be
automatically disqualifying
if they were presented
by whites and Asians.
So this idea that
racism is and sexism
are the things we should
be thinking about most
and that define everything
and are the reason to tear
down Western civilization
that now is the driving
force in the world at large
in the United States.
- Are you worried that the
backlash to what you just said
will actually start
a new type of racism
when the average
white kid or Asian
and you've written
a bunch about this.
When the average Asian kid
is going to have to
consistently score,
quite literally sometimes
20 percentage points higher
than the average
black or Latino kid.
You could see why someone
would become racist.
You should not become racist
but the system will
have reorganized things
in a way that will
breed resentment.
- Absolutely, and it's
only a matter of logic.
All you have to ask is, well,
why does every other group
get identity politics
and not whites?
Whatever you view of that
statement as a logical matter.
Now I guess they have
the whole argument about,
well blacks can't be racist
because they then define racism
to be something
accompanied by power
but if you're a
working class white,
you don't really
feel like you've got
a whole lot of white privilege
but you know right now
there's a professor in Florida
who is under enormous pressure
and he may even been
fired for talking
about black privilege.
And frankly, he's
absolutely right.
Again, if you're applying
to Google right now
and you're a black engineer,
you've got it made it.
You can just write your ticket,
you can ask for your salary.
Same if you're applying to be
a black chemistry professor
at Berkeley or Cal
Tech or Harvard,
the welcome mat is open for you.
Black privilege is real.
And so it is quite
logical for whites to say
or Asians to say, but Asians
are kind of allowed
ethnic identity
but if they can somehow claim
to be oppressed as well.
And it's very weird what
goes on with Asian identity
where they kind of wanna
be students of color
and then the administration
says, no, no, no,
you can't be students of color
because you're too
academically successful.
But you see this UC
Berkeley where they want
the victim status.
But yeah, maybe it will happen.
It's a question of sort
of the Trump deplorables
versus the elite whites and how
much they can suppress that.
But it is arguably bubbling
along under the surface.
- I fear that I know
your answer here
but are you surprised
at all to now see
that not only has this basically
decimated the universities
but we're seeing this now,
well, basically in every blue
city where now all of even
the private schools are being
infected with all of this,
that every, the charter schools,
of course the public schools
but basically schools that
were the elite schools
of New York City are
now instead of having,
a score-based admissions, we
have equity-based emissions.
They're gonna destroy
their own schools.
- Well, this has been
going on for a long time.
And sort of the, one
of the rules of media
is you have to pretend like
something you're saying
is for the first time, I mean,
I've wrote an article
years ago, decades ago
about elite prep schools
like Andover and Exeter
and in New England that were
already back in the '90's
embracing multiculturalism and
telling their black students
that they must
think of themselves
as oppressed and putting chips
on the shoulder of
everybody minority student.
But it certainly
is getting worse
and what I'm been
researching for a while now
and keep getting
distracted by other things.
But which breaks my heart to
pieces is the assault right now
on the thing I love most in
life which is classical music.
And what I've been noticing
is that there's not
a single guardian of our
great traditions of art
whether it's a museum director
or in the case of music
and orchestra, conductor,
orchestra manager,
a superstar singer or soloist,
certainly not the
classical music press
who is willing to
defend this tradition
of such sublime expression
of extraordinary variety
of human experience and
communication from the charge
that it is defined by racism
and white patriarchal power.
It is ludicrous, there's
a madman at Hunter College
which is one of
the city university
of New York colleges
in New York City.
A music theorist who's involved
in a very big spat right now
over a Vietnamese
music theorist known
as Carl Heinrich Schenker.
And this hunter music
theorist Phillip Ewell is mad.
He defines everything
in classical music
as a function of white maleness.
He says, well, Beethoven,
he said an okay composer.
But the only reason we
think of him as great
is because he's white male.
This is insane.
This is insane but it's
happening everywhere.
Everything is being torn down
and the people who have
been given the privilege
of defending and passing
on this inheritance
are cowards and they have
all rolled over and play dead
and said, of course, our
inheritance is racist
and we are now from here
on in gonna make decisions
based-on the trivialities
of gonads and melanin
- (laughs) I'm guessing
that gonads and melanin
that could be the title of
your next book, first off.
That was (speakers
laughs) gonad and melanin.
Do you get a lot of academics
reaching out to you,
telling you their
version of this story?
And do they ever do anything?
I mean what percentage do
you think actually speak up.
My inbox is almost
like a therapy session
from these people at this point.
- Yeah, they're terrified.
There's I just find it amazing
that the left claims
that cancel culture,
you guys are just victim
whiners, it doesn't exist.
What are you talking about?
Again, there's a perceptual
divide here that is so massive.
And I despair how you bridge it.
But the left really
does not think
that they're censoring
people, but yes,
practically every
single faculty member
and every conservative student
is walking around
scared to death
that he's gonna be the
next one to fall under.
And what really worries
me and Dave you know
you are a premier
exponent of free speech.
Conservative newspaper, student
newspapers are so essential.
I was not a conservative
as a college student.
So this was and I don't
even know back in the '70's
if there was a conservative
newspaper at Yale.
I think probably not, it
was much less political time
but they are essential.
Well, what's been
going on recently
now that sort of seems
like ancient history
during the Trump era,
he would nominate judges
to the federal bench
and their enemies would dig
up writings of these students
from their college time.
There was a guy that went to
Stanford who was nominated
for the ninth circuit and
he wrote some very scathing
and satirical pieces
about multiculturalism.
Well, he was denied the going
forward with nomination,
not just by the Democrats
but by Marco Rubio
and Tim Scott, their
eternal discredit.
Naomi route did squeak
through but she was critical
of the campus rape culture
and she had to backtrack
and confess her sins
and say, oh, well,
of course there's rape
culture when there is not.
But what I'm worried
about is any students
who is forward-oriented
and future-oriented
will say, I don't
dare write the truth
about what's going on
a college campus today
because that's gonna be used
against me in my next job.
And so you've got a very
subtle self censorship
that's going on that
means that the truth
is gonna get harder and
harder to get around.
- I'm reminded of
an event that I did
at University of New Hampshire
a couple of years ago
that went viral where there
was a whole bunch of protestors
and kids were screaming
at me and this one girl,
a brown skin girl she
happened to be brown skinned
doesn't matter to me
but I'm mentioning it
because it gives
context to the story.
She started screaming at
me heckling and saying,
"That I could be killed
when I walk out of here."
And I thought, wait, it's
the middle of the day
in New Hampshire, are
students being killed?
But I realized
what she was saying
was so emotionally
disconnected from reality
that there was virtually
nothing that I could say to her.
And it became very clear that
there was nothing I could say
to her to calm down.
But they had ginned up such
an irrational fear in her
that it had almost,
in essence taken over every
other faculty that she has.
- And these are the
universities that are supposedly
that still present themselves
to these idiotic donors
who keep funneling
truckloads of cash
into their mall to
be used for more hate
and victimology and
destruction of our traditions.
These are the colleges
that are teaching them
this fantastical delusion
that they are at risk
and it is what is now
in our cultural large
whether it's the
idea that children
shouldn't be in school because
of COVID or again, people,
I'm here in Orange
County and it's better,
my pool rules here are
better than the New York
but otherwise I walk in
the faculty housing area
of University of
California, Irvine
as early as I can get out there
to avoid the faculty members
at 6:00 a.m. again.
You're out in this huge
pressure, they're wearing masks
are you people insane?
But that, one feels alive
in being frightened.
And we all see
this now with this,
I would argue completely
fantastical narrative
that the world is under threat
from white supremacist
violence and pouring troops.
They keep coming
into the Capitol,
they're coming into
every other capital
in this sort of deliberate
theater supporting
the lie that the country's
biggest threat right now
is these cooks that
got out of control
and were horribly ill-mannered
and disgusting in the Capitol.
But that was a one-off and
it is not the character
of our country right now
but that is another sort
of safety is a lie that
is now a typical
product of the Academy.
- I wanna dive into that
'cause I know you have a bunch
of talk about there but
just before we do that,
I think it'll segue
sort of nicely
as you've mentioned
multiculturalism a few times
and I think when the average
person hears the phrase,
multiculturalism,
they think, yes,
we should be a
multicultural society.
Isn't that what we are my
neighbors from this country,
my aunt is from that
country, blah, blah,
aren't we multicultural
but there's a distinct
difference between
multiculturalism
and the way that America
has done the melting pot.
Is that a fair statement?
And can you explain
it a little bit
'cause I think people
once they hear you say,
I'm against multiculturalism,
they automatically
think that that
has some racist beginning
to it, you know?
- Well, the reality
that the empirical fact
of multiculturalism
it is not inclusive,
it's not additive,
it is subtractive.
It is done in the name of
labeling the Western tradition
which has been encyclopedic.
It has been inclusive
and it's taken in people
from across the globe to
put that to denigrate it
and to teach students and adults
to see it through the lens
of oppression which is just
tragic, utterly tragic.
And the multicultural idea
is one that is antithetical
to the power of the
human imagination.
I don't know if there's a
single more idiotic conception
than the one of
cultural appropriation
that is trying to
draw boundaries
around the human imagination
and say that if you're say
a white female writer,
you cannot write a novel
that has a black male
protagonist in it
because that would be
culturally appropriate of,
are you kidding me?
There's the greatest artists
of our time have seen
into people very
different than themselves.
I've seen some of the most
extraordinary explorations
of female sexual
jealousy by male writers
who simply possessed
the feature of empathy.
So multiculturalism as
practiced and as given
within our world today
is not saying let's,
yes, let's learn the great epic
traditions of India or China
but rather it means
that, hey, hey,
hou, hou, Western
Civs has got to go
which is the Jesse
Jackson infamous chant
from Stanford of '80's
that's the reality of it.
And the other reality is frankly
as inclusive it has been,
it is a European tradition
and it is white, sorry,
mostly not exclusively
but there weren't a
whole lot of blacks
writing Renaissance madrigals.
So if you're an
early music group,
doing Baroque music
and you've now decided
your mission is social
justice and your mission
is to be an anti-racism
organization
which music organization
after music organization
is declaring itself as our
mission is to be anti-racist.
So just the reality
of history is
there not a lot of
black composers.
The reason there's
not black composers
is not because of racism.
It's because that's what
the demographics were.
Nobody goes to African
music and says, well,
we can't perform it
because there's no whites
or we can't do bolo
me as the monkey chant
because there were no
British whites in there.
There are certain
realities of history
and population groups that
that's just what history is.
You cannot change it.
- All right, so let's shift
to where you were going there
about the Capitol Hill protest.
Are you telling me
Heather Mac Donald,
that man with the horns
and the face paint,
that that guy was not the
leader of a giant coup,
they weren't going to take
over the entire
government that day.
Because if you watch
CNN, Jake Tapper,
there was an insurrection,
these people were going to take
over all of our
governmental institutions.
- Well, I am not going to
defend them for an instant.
And I cannot state enough that
as a prerequisite prolegomena
to everything I'm saying,
I'm not justifying them,
I'm not making an
apology for them.
But this was a one-off.
This was the moment that
the left has been hoping for
that we were told
it was gonna happen
after the election
never happened
and these guys got
out of control.
It is also true that as we heard
with the Black Lives
Matter protest,
we've heard for the
riots, the race riots
that did a 100,000 times
more damage than happened
as a physical matter
and as a life matter
than happened on January 6th.
The rolling riots that
we saw over the summer
through the fall that are now
being completely rewritten
out of history by
the mainstream media,
not that they acknowledged
them at all at the time
but now they're being
completely erased,
those were far more destructive
in terms of property damage
and damage to government
property than anything
that happened on January 6th.
I simply do not believe
that what happened then
represents an ongoing
terror threat.
These people are disorganized,
they're losers, they
got out of control
and they have been in the grips
of what I would
say is a delusion
which is the idea
that the election
was systematically rigged.
One's attitude towards
what went on on January 6th
to a certain extent
will be influenced
by whether you believe
the rigging narrative.
They believe it.
And if the election
was systemically rigged
that is very serious
business that undermines
the legitimacy of our government
and justifies something.
It doesn't justify violence
but it justifies something.
And so that makes
this whole debate
about what went on complicated
because there's a factual
dispute at the heart
of both sides.
- From a legal perspective,
do you think Trump
was inciting them
when he was saying,
I mean, he did
repeatedly say peaceful
but I think what a lot
of people are saying is,
well, what did he think
was going to happen
when they got there?
I mean, actually I think had
things not gotten out of hand,
Ted Cruz would have issued
a statement that day saying,
I object to this or
that and Rand Paul
would have done the same.
The day would have finished up.
And then actually, what
I think what happened
was people would have
realized it was over.
I think that's where
it was all heading.
- Yeah, I'm not an expert
on the laws of incitement.
So I'm not, I don't know
what the legal standards are
but it's complicated.
I mean he's got
statements and again,
this is what's difficult is how
you view what he
said does depend
on what your view is of the
underlying claim of rigging.
You can't get around that.
If you think the rigging idea
was preposterous as I do,
then for him to go and say,
take back the capital sounds
possibly too provocative
but if it's right, if he
really was the rightful winner
and the election
was stolen from him
then his rhetoric
looks simply factual.
- I want to stop you
there for a second
'cause it's interesting
because even though
you're really just talking
about sort of the sort
of psychological makeup
of some of the people
in the behaviors related
to the information that we all
get I know it's very possible
that YouTube is going
to take this video down
because we're really not even
supposed to talk about this
even though you're fully
saying that you believe
that the election was legitimate
but that's the sort
of information war
that we're in related
to all of this.
- The question Dave is what is
this country gonna look like
in five years or three years?
This censorship is happening
so quickly, I mean,
my mind is just blown by it.
I don't know what one can do.
And the other thing
that worries me
and this comes out
of the Academy again.
Up to now, federal judges
have been pretty good
in striking down free
speech limitations
on college campuses which
the things that get appealed
to them tend to be
the speech codes
which are by now
are sort of archaic
and a trivial problem compared
to the much broader campus
climate of censorship.
But the judges have been
pretty good on first amendment
but what are future
judges gonna be like?
They're the product of
this academy as well.
And during the Brett
Kavanaugh hearings
you had students from the
Harvard and Yale law schools
protesting saying,
believe survivors.
Trying to torpedo the
Kavanaugh nomination,
the believe survivors mantra
that is the absolute central
plank of feminism today
is completely antithetical
to due process.
It is the rejection of the
presumption of innocence.
The hate speech conceit that
we're seeing now weaponized
in the world at large
to do censorship
when you have
members of the press
saying we should
censor Fox news,
we should deep
platform everybody
because hate speech is behavior,
speech destroys people's lives
as you pointed out
and hate speech
is not a constitutionally
protected or
recognized category.
The judges that
we are entrusting
with our constitution are
the products of the academy
that is giving us
these poisonous ideas.
So I don't know how much
longer we can count on America
the way we know it to advance.
- I mean, it's scary
what you're saying there
but I think what I hear from
a lot of conservatives is,
oh, the courts are the
sort of last line on this.
That may be Trump got
enough judges in for now
'cause he did get a lot of,
I mean it was something like
400 judges if I'm not mistaken.
He got a ton of judges in
that that's the last line
but I think you're right,
it's also that
they're a function
of the culture and
everything else.
And the more we target
individual people
and then they get scared and
they don't wanna be called
a racist on top of the
fact that they themselves
may have been indoctrinated
at some level,
it's a scary stew.
Let me shift to something
that you might find
a little more inspiring then.
I was at the Turning Point
USA Student Action Summit
right before Christmas.
And we've talked
about this before
but you're a
non-religious conservative
which sometimes people
find to be an oxymoron.
I do not and we've had a
couple of interesting chats
about it but at turning point,
they had a conservative
secular coalition there.
It was the first time this
group had been invited
and there were a
lot of them there.
I did an interview with
them and as I was talking,
I think I brought you
up in the interview
but I see something really
nice happening there
that there suddenly
is this sort of burst
of secular conservatism.
And I thought you might
just like to hear that.
- Interesting, no, I
was unaware of that.
That's fantastic.
It doesn't necessarily change
a lot of the other rhetoric
that comes out of a lot of
conservative talk show hosts
but you know, again,
if we really believe
in being inclusive
that's a good thing,
that seem to be the
overriding idea.
So sort of going
back a little bit
to the censorship part of this
has any of the big
tech censorship,
the way they're trying
to kick Fox off the air,
to get rid of you tubers
or saying that you can't talk
about any of these things,
has any of that pushed
your free market principles
to the breaking point.
That seems to be a new
place that libertarians
and conservatives are
fighting at the moment like,
oh, we should have used
the power of the government
when we had Trump to break
up the tech monopolies
or do you fully believe
in the free market
or some combination thereof?
- Yeah, this again
is not my expertise.
And I am, the big thing
that I find so astounding
with the members of the liberal
elites that are calling now
from censorship is their
child-like inability
to think in terms of principles,
they think that they
will always have power
and that therefore they
can establish the precedent
of a shutting down speech
that will never be
used against them.
And you think my God,
an adult is supposed
to be able to abstract from
his own situation to think
in terms of neutral principles.
And I used to go around
to college campuses
and say to the lefty students
who were yes also screaming
and having heart attacks
at my very presence,
they're saying, do you want
this power of censorship
in the hands of Donald Trump?
And ironically Trump did
not try to censor people
but now you have Max Boot
and Washington post writers
and heads of Columbia
Journalism School saying,
well, this free speech thing
is not really so great,
we've got to get rid of it
but what if we get Trump
in 2024, God forbid
or somebody else it's
gonna use it against you
and I would still, I
would say the same thing
with taking on the big tech
companies that they are private.
And so I'm worried about
any kind of precedent
that would be used
for government to go
after a private entity because
we may think we're doing it
in a good cause now but
the tables can always turn
but this is something that
is above my pay grade.
I leave it to you to figure
out a way out of the mess
because it's done part.
- I know the tech
part isn't necessarily
your area of expertise but I
knew you could give me a sort
of philosophical
underpinning there.
But all right so going
back to a little bit more
of where you focus.
We have heard Joe Biden
say the phrase equity,
roughly 1 billion
times in his few weeks
of I'll have to get
fact checked on that,
but in his few weeks of office.
I mean, equity, equity, equity.
You may remember that just
what two or three days
before the election Kamala
Harris released that video
on Twitter, talking about
that we should all end up
in the same place.
This is obviously very
different than equality.
Are you kind of shocked
or does it just all fit
that we sort of slipped equity
under the guise of
equality into the system
just that quickly where now
if you say you're against equity
which is just sort of
an imaginary position,
well, of course you're
racist and everything else?
- Yeah, well, equity is another,
it's a synonym for the
sort of the adverse
which is racism and white
supremacy I've been hearing
more of my year more attuned
to Biden's endless repetition
of systemic racism.
And they're the same thing.
I mean, equity is the
response to systemic racism.
Equity means quotas, it
means the destruction
of meritocratic standards.
It means you hire and
promote on the basis of race
not on the basis
of qualifications
and any institution
which does not show
a proportional number
of blacks or Hispanics
is thereby by definition
systemically racist
and engaged in bias.
And I'm fully expecting
Abraham Candy,
the big anti-racist
huckster right now
who's probably the most
highest paid of them.
He may have even bumped
out Ta-Nehisi Coates
to end up in the
federal government
and start up an agency of
anti-racism that will go
after every private
institutions using
the completely dangerous
and unjustified tool
of disparate impact which
holds that any neutral process
such as saying we expect you
as a Alzheimer's researcher
to have a highly
competitive knowledge
of the way neurology works.
If that standard has a
disparate impact on blacks
then you get rid of
the standard and say,
we're gonna replace with quotas.
The fact of the matter is
the academic skills gap
in this country is so vast
that it is preposterous
to claim that the lack of
proportional representation
in any institution is
the result of bias.
The facts are these,
black eighth graders,
54% of all black eighth
graders in this country,
do not even have
basic math skills,
basic as defined by the
National Association
of Educational
Progress, the NAEP
as partial mastery
of math concepts,
54% of black eighth
graders are below basic
in their math skills.
40% are below basic and
their reading skills that is,
they do not even
have partial mastery
of eighth grade reading skills.
That gap does not close.
It continues at the SAT
level where you have
a standard deviation of
gap LSAT's, GMAT's, MCAT's
everywhere you see
that distinction.
- And by the way, their response
is to now get rid of many
of these things, right?
- Right, exactly.
They're gonna get rid of that
that's why they're
getting rid of the SATs.
And my prediction is
we are also eventually
gonna get rid of crime data.
You are gonna have
police departments,
it's already very
hard to get your hands
on crime offending data
and criminal victimization
data as well.
And that is eventually going
to be repressed as well
in order to further
strengthen the phony narrative
that the disproportion of blacks
in the prison system
is due to racism
not to exponentially higher
rates of criminal offending.
- So I think when some
people hear you say that
when they hear, okay, well,
54% of black eighth graders
aren't at that
level or the level
that they should be at
that they say, well,
then that proves
that they're systemic racism.
If it's so disproportionate
to black people,
I think at a surface
level thought,
I think that's
what happens there.
So can you just go a
little bit beneath that,
maybe as a comparison
to the Asian community
because I know you've
written a lot about that.
- Well, I proposed
a thought experiment
which is that if blacks acted
like Asians for 10 years
in all regards to things
that have a bearing
on academic success
on success in life
such as being fanatical
about schoolwork,
having parents that care about
whether you're going to class,
whether you're truant or not,
taking your textbooks home,
studying for the next exam,
not screaming at your teacher,
beating up your teacher,
not getting involved
in drugs or gangs,
having a very low out
of wedlock birth rate,
if all those behaviors
were the same
and then we saw
the socioeconomic
disparities that we do
then it would be
more than enough time
to start talking
about systemic racism.
But right now you have a culture
and you have addressed this day
with your fantastic interview
with Brandon of Brexit,
a inner city culture that
stigmatizes academic effort
that celebrates
violence, criminality
that is completely
inimical to success in life
when the behaviors
are so different,
it is way premature to
talk about systemic racism.
There is a lot that can be
done at least in theory.
I mean, we've been
trying for decades
without a whole lot of success
but it remains theoretically
possible to change the culture
and the behaviors that I
think are clearly related
to the fact that we don't
have absolute equity
in outcomes that Kamala Harris
and Biden pretend to want.
And as long as we can note,
can't talk about those behaviors
and we keep going down this
path of demanding more quotas,
more transfer payments,
nothing is going to change.
- Yeah, and by the
way, of course,
the great Thomas Soul has been
talking about this forever.
That that in effect is
what the welfare state did.
Do you think there's anything
though the government could do?
Let's say we had a government,
certainly not the
government we have
at the federal level now
but if there was a government
to come in and say,
okay, we want to
address these issues
around the family, around
generations on welfare,
all of these things
we want to address it.
What do you do?
I mean, I've heard some
people like Candace Owens say,
you just stopped the
programs tomorrow
and you let that pain point hit.
Do you think there's a
sensible policy there?
Do you say, just end everything?
What's the actual
action that can happen?
- Government cannot
do social uplift,
it doesn't know how to do it.
And of course right now
you have government,
the social work schools are
cranking out government workers
that are utterly committed
to non-judgmentalism
when it comes to self
destructive behavior.
Like I remember in
the 90's in New York,
I used to write a lot
about welfare reform
and would talk to these
non-profit workers
and they were adamant
that they couldn't say
a word about out of
wedlock childbirth
which is the biggest predictor
of poverty in this country.
If we could wipe out out
of wedlock childbearing,
reunite families together
we'd get rid of poverty
and we'd get rid
of almost all crime
and it's it's happening now in
the white community as well.
The Hillbilly Elegy
population as well.
Charles Murray has
written about that.
So government does not know
how to change
people's upbringing.
So yes, it would
be a great thing.
I would absolutely back Candace
Owens of going cold turkey
and there were
proposals about that
during the welfare
reform era of the 1990's
of at least not
giving more checks,
larger checks when people had
more children out of wedlock
but that was a very hard sell.
I would say government,
what it's there for
is providing public order,
providing the basis for people
to exercise their own initiative
that is above all safe streets
so that businesses
don't have to worry
about their employees,
they can set up shop
and people can thrive and get
where they need to
go without fear.
- You're speaking my language.
It's so interesting what
you said about in the '90's
and the social workers
and they couldn't bring up
the one parent household.
It reminds me of something
that David Horowitz
who I'm sure you know
have told me once
when he was still a lefty
in New York City politics
in the early '80's
during the AIDS crisis,
they or he was just
sort of becoming
a Republican in essence.
And they knew that
the AIDS crisis
that in effect ground zero
was these gay bathhouses
'cause people were
having all kinds of sex
and doing drugs and
all sorts of stuff.
And the Republicans wanted
to close down the bath houses
but the Democrats said, no,
you're a bunch of homophobes
and you hate gay people
thus they actually extended
the crisis probably
for years and years after that
because it's just, it's the
same culture of fear in essence.
- Well, I've said the big
divide between conservatives
and liberals or
progressives you left is
whether you see behavior
as the most important
determinant of life outcomes
or you see large systemic
structures as the determinant.
And I'm sure there's
counter examples here
but by and large, a liberal
is gonna say but look,
there's these huge structures,
homophobia or racism
that prevent people
from thriving.
And again, in the case of AIDS,
I mean it was just remarkable
that we were not allowed
to talk about grotesquely
promiscuous sex.
And pretending that AIDS
is like an airborne disease
and infectious disease as
opposed to something that is
almost 100% avoidable by
not doing intravenous drugs
and not engaging
in anonymous sex
with people who you have
no idea what their STDs
status is or anything.
You can avoid it 100%.
And so a conservatives
is gonna focus on
those behavioral
choices that people make
and be more skeptical
and a liberal would say,
how can you be so blind to the
systemic structural barriers?
And that's, again, it's one of
those constitutional divides
in how we look at the world
that is very hard to bridge.
- Do you I think the more
and more you do these things
that you study these things,
talk about these things
and the more we've seen so much
of what you talk
about come true.
Do you ultimately think that
it's partly just the way
our brains are wired at the end
that it's just some
people's fear center is this
and some people's other
fear center is that
so the mask then, if for some
people you walk around and go,
man, these people are bananas
that's sort of where I'm at
but then someone else
thinks it actually
in some ways giving them
purpose in a bizarre sense.
- That's absolutely right.
It does give you purpose and
you feel like you're part
of something bigger
and fear is as I say,
it gives you feel
like you're alive
and it also gives you virtue.
Yeah, I do and I also
think we're all susceptible
to enormous cognitive
blindnesses,
and so I'm sure conservatives
are just as inconsistent
in their application
of principles.
So I mean, we've all seen the
sort of seesaw go up and down
as to whether one's in
favor of executive orders
based on whether your
guy's in office or not.
So I do kind of despair.
I mean, I have to say,
and this is going to anger
a lot of people and
alienated a lot of people
but I have been depressed
by seeing the willingness
of so many people on
the right to embrace
what I think are just
completely ridiculous
conspiracy theories with regards
to dominion voting systems
and to not apply the Hume test,
the test for miracles of
having a basic skepticism
towards claims which ask
is it more likely than not?
Is it more likely than not
that there was a
systemic conspiracy
across all levels of
government in this country
to destroy Trump votes?
To me that it's a step too far
but people have
selective rationality.
And so I think that kind
of a libertarian view
that views everybody is it's
all gonna come out all right
in the wash because
we're all rational.
It's not quite the way it works.
And we've had people
like Daniel Conaman
for years now point out sort
of failures of how human
beings are wired cognitively
and tendency towards see
agency where it doesn't exist.
I would say that's part of
the religious impulse as well.
So one can only hope and
make those arguments as often
as one can from one's own
perspective of rationality
knowing that we are
I am fallible too.
And I think we need some
epistemological humility
towards our own positions
even as we're criticizing
what appear to be complete
insanity on the side
of ideological opponents.
- That probably is the
right place to stop
because it was a
beautiful ending
but I'm going to
push you one further
which is that my audience knows
that I'm really trying to help
people just not feel crazy
about all of this 'cause the
world really does feel crazy.
We're watching the
close of the old world,
we're watching the
beginning of a new world
that is going to feel very
different no matter what.
I sense you're probably similar
to the way I think of myself.
I consider myself a
world weary optimist
but really a real list
more than anything else.
I think you probably, you
certainly must consider yourself
a realist but can you
track some sort of future
that looks okay over the
next couple of years?
Like is there something
that you can sort of see
in the distance that's like, oh,
we can get through this without
the complete destruction
of everything that
you know is good.
- The truth, I mean, I just
and I'm not a world
very optimist,
I'm a world very pessimistic.
(interviewer laughing)
Again, this to constitution,
I can tell, I'm not
an optimist by nature
and I know that clouds
how I see things
and I find optimist crazy like,
how can you guys think
it's gonna get better?
It's not, but let's
pretend, but no,
there are ways, the only way
out of this is the truth,
do not be cowed by
the charge of racism.
I do believe that the
core problem in all
of our world today
is the racial gap, the idea
that America is racist,
white supremacy that's
driving an enormous portion
of the current insanity.
We have to speak the truth
about accomplishment,
about culture and
not allow our history
and our civilization
to be torn down
based on hatred,
resentment and mediocrity.
Stick up for what you love.
I'm gonna stick up for
the art that I think is
is greater than any of us
have any right to deserve,
we do not deserve
the beauty of Chopin
and Brahms piano music
and Mozart Operas.
None of us have done
anything to justify
this cornucopia of sublimity.
Keep fighting for it.
Keep fighting for what
you believe with respect,
not violence that's all you
can do is just go down fighting
at the very least.
- Heather Mac Donald,
you are truly one
of my favorite guests.
Your most recent book is
the "Diversity Delusion"
which we'll link
to right down below
and you're in Odyssey,
I'm here in LA
maybe we meet in the
middle for coffee.
I don't want to get arrested.
We'll see what happens.
- (laughs) We'll wear our mask,
two mask I know you should have
- We'll double up,
we'll double up.
- Thank you so much Heather.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.